71 years ago
george orwell wrote a prescient passage
about the manipulation of
language in politics one ought to
recognize that the present political
chaos
is connected with the decay of language
political language is designed to make
lies sound truthful and murder
respectable
and to give an appearance of solidity to
pure wind
well back then orwell was writing about
the rise of communism in the far left
thought
today with the rise of the hard left in
america
we should keep orwell's warnings in mind
and learn to spot
lies that are made to sound truthful
during this pivotal time
now lucky for you we're here and we're
going to help decode
and translate the language of the
democrats and their media allies this
campaign season
first up what they're saying about virus
strategy
they need leadership they need a plan i
wish we had a national plan everybody's
confused this is a time
that we should be talking with one very
clear very consistent voice
where was the national strategy where
was the national leadership
it didn't exist okay translation
when they say national strategy they
mean
national lockdown it is abundantly clear
that they want to shut down the entire
country
until the virus either magically
disappear on its own
or until there is an effective safe
vaccine which even dr fauci has to say
may never come and think about
cuomo for a moment with his deadly covet
record
he should be run out of politics forever
not be held up as some type of
anti-coveted superhero
and here's your nightly reminder new
york's deaths
account for nearly a quarter of all
deaths in the united states
they've had nearly 13 times more deaths
per thousand hundred thousand than
texas and seven and a half times more
than florida
now recall also that california speaking
of strategy
they instituted a strict lockdown and
now they still have rising infections
it obviously didn't work it prolonged
the inevitable
so the national leadership they're
craving for has to be just
another lockdown this time a national
lockdown period
no exceptions and biden can't admit this
we of course he can and the media is not
going to press him on it certainly for
any specifics of his solution
because they know it's not popular but
moving on
decoding the democrats on race
americans are in the streets demanding
racial justice
i think that the right thing to do for
our country moving forward
is to guarantee health care pay people a
living wage
support labor rights and make sure that
we're doing that with a lens of racial
and social
uh justice now is the time for racial
justice
okay what does racial justice mean i'll
tell you what it means it means
empowering groups that pretend to care
about minorities
but actually just end up profiting
themselves by stoking racial animosity
under abide administration decisions
will be made
largely based on race not on merit or
hard work or achievement
those words themselves remember come
from white privilege they're telling us
now
so get ready for massive discrimination
against i don't know more than 100
million americans
as special privileges accommodations and
money
are doled out to certain politically
preferred groups
and on foreign policy well democrats say
they're going to need to rebuild
all of our international relationships
the challenge
of following this disastrous presence
however
will not be just to restore the
reputation our credibility
it will be to enact a forward-looking
foreign policy
for the world as we find it today
translation get ready for another
apology tour biden is going to go around
the world
begging america's pardon after all
having a president who
actually fought for and fights for our
american workers
and is tough on trade he's not giving
away the store like obama did you think
the europeans like that
that's why a europe would probably love
a biden presidency
because they know he'll do pretty much
everything europe wants
and as far as china is concerned
remember biden said they weren't even a
threat
expected dismantling of all tariffs huge
concessions by the united states
and the continued outsourcing of
american jobs
oh what about health care well it's
still the old if you like your plan
you can keep it healthcare guaranteed as
human right
but taking away the right to have a
private plan if you want a private
plan i disagree with no okay but here's
here's a member of biden's own unity
health care tax
task force talking about how she and the
progressives
were able to move biden to the left
we did a lot of good work together to
really
push the vice president's health care
platform
much further than it's been before to
take elements of medicare for all
and put it into the platform
into the platform of course they mean
government-run health care they've
already embraced free healthcare for
illegal immigrants
and i think to really understand what's
in store for us
look no further than this chilling
account from the guardian newspaper
today it was written by a woman
with late stage cancer about her delayed
treatment from the national health
service
the operation finally took place on 27
february almost five months after the
cancer had recurred
once he'd taken a look inside my surgeon
closed me up again
with a heavy heart it was now impossible
to remove
all the cancerous tissue they got there
too late
it's a heartbreak on taxes
they're selling the same stale lines
i think we should raise taxes on the
wealthy pass a wealth tax
and protect our democracy let's help
millions of would-be entrepreneurs get
out from under their debts
so they can start businesses and it's
time
corporate america paid their fair share
of taxes
fair share translation it's back to the
failed policies of the 1970s
when the top marginal rates were 70 it's
not going to be just for corporations
and of course a tax rate that high just
hurts working men and women
wall street bankers and k street
lobbyists they can always find ways
around paying these exorbitant rates
but that's their plan to punish everyone
who works for a living
then dole out the money they have to
programs like i don't know let's go back
to midnight basketball
the tax policy center estimated that joe
biden's agenda would raise taxes
by four trillion dollars over the next
decade
more than twice as big as a tax raise as
proposed by hillary clinton
in 2016. and speaking of fairness
the rich already pay their fair share
check this out the average household in
the top
1 retains almost 18 times as much income
after taxes and transfer payments as the
bottom
fifth but pays more than 219
times as much in taxes
as we move through this campaign season
i'm going to be doing more decoding for
you but
i have to admit there are some people in
the democrat party
who really are saying what they mean
they were criticizing like why use the
word defund why use the word defund and
it's like this
is the word that's coming from the
streets this is about true reparations
our first responders have a role to play
in society
but they need to play a role in every
part of society we must begin the work
of dismantling the whole system of
oppression
wherever we find it well there's no
translation needed here
the they're actually telling the truth
they mean it when they say it
this is what they're planning they're
already doing it in places like
minneapolis and l.a
on most big issues of the past year the
squad
has been the democratic thought leader
from climate change to impeachment to
defunding the police
and they'll all continue to be key
influencers in a biden administration
you bet
and if you think biden is going to stop
them
you're you're just either naive or
haven't been paying any attention
biden will be nothing more than an oval
office bobble bobblehead
nodding along with whatever far leftists
appears before him at any given time
biden's no longer the moderate of yore
he's moved so far left to satiate the
mob that he'll have to continue doing so
or else
they're going to surround his new house
and then burn things around it until he
does
and do you think biden is going to call
up the national guard to protect
monuments or even the white house no way
they'll get them out through the tunnel
i'm confident
despite all of this despite all the
decoding we're going to have to do that
come fall many more americans will
understand the orwellian
chasm that you're going to get thrown
into
under a biden administration wouldn't
you rather be
decoding and exposing the radical agenda
than actually
living under it and that's the angle